beca's in Carson City Nevada I back up
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi my
question is okay so I'm legally married
to the same person for the last five
years we're unable to get a divorce
because there's children involved and we
can't find him to serve Him so I was
wondering where would I start in this
whole program so that way I'm not paying
off his debt because I don't think any
of his debt on my credit I just don't
want anything to be applied to him to
help him I'm the one with the children
okay well I'm not a not an attorney but
I don't think that's correct that you
have to serve him if you a certain
period of time has gone by and the guy's
just gone there ought to be a process
you can use in court to walk you through
this I think you may need a different
attorney yeah we are researching that
part right down to it's just been a very
long process but I want to start it
doesn't need to be a long process it
needs to be over I know the anyway the
the here's the here's the concern okay
yeah you could get your debt paid off
and work yours off and build up some
savings and start to build wealth and go
on and and then he shows up and gets
half of it exactly that's the problem
that's why we need to get this final or
some kind of legal separation or some
kind of documentation you know again I'm
not an attorney and I'm certainly not an
attorney in Nevada so you'd want someone
that knows the law in your state but is
there something where you know from this
date forward we can keep his hands out
of your pockets because this is the kind
of guy who will show up about the time
you've got some money and I so I don't
want you to stay broke just as a
protection against a put
seneschal parasite right but on the
other hand we need to be wise about this
so you know it's more of a legal battle
and a legal issue than it is a financial
issue you need to do something so that
you can begin your life financially you
do something in the in the courts
whether it's a legal separation
whether it's filing you know whatever
you've got a file that you can't find
him or whatever the process is but I can
probably solve that if I'm you in about
two weeks
somebody's gonna get to the bottom of
this and we're gonna settle this this is
not gonna drag on five more years and
you've gotten out of debt and built up
your 401k to a half million dollars and
then he shows up and has legal rights to
half of it because of marital laws and
Nevada I don't know but that's that's my
fear so I'm not gonna I can't give you a
structure or a process to protect you
other than divorce and so that needs to
happen in this case I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're facing all that but yeah you need
to get so you can start your life you
know and you're you're kind of held in
limbo is what it amounts to so that you
can then work get your debts paid off
yeah
get yours paid off whatever's in his
name likely you could get it handed to
him in a divorce court but again the
more this drags out and the more you
build wealth the more muddy this water
is going to be when you do finally get
everything drawn to a head and it needs
to be